here with Fabiano Carona who never
disappoints in his opening preparation
Father tell us a little bit about this
one it's a little bit off the trodden
path but you seem to make it work very
easily I mean I can't really call it
deep preparation this was played in a
Blitz game between Jan and Richie in
like in Paris up to up to Bishop takes
e66 BC Rook B6 I I think he didn't play
H6
but like up to 21 this was played in The
Blitz game oh the entire thing we must
have missed that we don't have Blitz
Games on our database we apologize for
that it was it was in the grand chess
tour and we do see a lot of games
you're forgiving for that thank you so
why do you think he went for this
variation it does seem that it doesn't
offer that many chances for well the
opening was just a surprise for him I
mean I've never played this this four
nights with Bishop B4 I mean usually if
I play four nights I try to get a
question called and I think that's what
he was aiming for some sort of
complicated question call
fight and I surprised him and you know
white doesn't have so many Alternatives
um it's a relatively foreseen line there
are some Alternatives but you have to to
know what they are and and some details
about them so he
okay I think Bishop takes G6 is just a
better chance than Bishop C6 we go back
to uh here Bishop takes on G6 it's it's
also super Josh Rook B6
I mean but why it does remain up a pawn
right black doesn't get the pawn back
immediately Knight D4 C3 Knight C2 Rook
C1 right there's a game actually of
adiban in this position yeah Knight
takes eight I I guess
um
I guess he made a drawn I I must have
seen this game but I no I was actually
one he lost his game okay yeah so the
line goes relaxed sorry black lost that
game was white okay now I understand
yeah rupee seven I mean it remains
tricky black plays F6 this should be
three Knight C4 the bishop we should go
to D Port is the best square and then
it's very important to play G5 to stop
H4 we're considering that because in the
long term G7 might be a weakness black
needs a structure with the with the
g-pawn and it's not like black gets the
pawn back you know white plays this
position and black basically has some
sort of Fortress I mean it doesn't look
like a fortress but white can't really
make progress in the long run and uh so
you're confident making a draw from this
position I thought so I mean I knew more
or less that a pair of Rooks will get
traded a lot of people play Rook C2 at
some point to stop the invasion of Rook
A2 bring the king to the center and
black will also bring the king to the
center and and we'll read reach some
sort of impasse like for example Rook C7
Rook fc8 take take King G1
on a rook A8 Rook C2 king of Southern
King F2 King E6 can you like this
position something like this right yeah
and uh of course it's not fun but if you
know that it's it should be a draw then
then you kind of figure it out
um
so yeah this is a slightly better chance
than the opposite colored Bishops
although I felt like I got under
pressure with some inaccurate play in
the game you it felt that you had to
solve a few problems but that you had it
all under control was there a particular
moment when you felt under danger no
just I I played this um which one was it
when I played G5 I don't think this is
necessary I mean G5 in this position
yeah maybe something like Bishop T6 is
more just keeping the position yeah
because then then it becomes concrete
after Bishop d8 this what happened in
the game right like yeah so here I could
have played
um
King G6 Rook D3 and I could have played
Bishop to E6 yes and then Rook D6
King F5
um I actually measured G5 uh yeah King
F5 Bishop G5 I think is the best chance
King G5 because okay I don't know Rook
A3 is a bit dangerous I mean black is
really tied up so King G5 so you don't
want to go into this you want to take
here and then make this cake and and
this type of ending is a draw
but it's not a fun one no and I was like
I spent like 20 minutes thinking about
this position trying to remember what I
what I knew about this ending
um because white basically plays like
Rook E1 King back Rook F1 G3 King H3 F4
and then and this is the plan oh let me
put this King somewhere
yeah well it's like King H3 wait Rook F1
weight G3
yeah and now F4
King goes back
Rook B1 I mean this stuff is very
dangerous because the Rook invades uh
I I couldn't even remember exactly how
black draws I think like there's there's
only one one
um method in which black draws its
position so it's it's not didn't seem
easy and I decided not to go for this
so instead you went for the move H4
check kept the Bishops on the board a
couple tricks here but nothing really
worked for him yeah I didn't see
anything in particular but it wasn't
super fun to play this after Bishop B7
there was a I think Rook D4 was
important let me go back to 39 39
Bishops if I play G4
then Bishop B4 I think I might lose this
because it just traps the rope in the
wrong side not only that but I made it
after detail
like if I could play G3 King G1 and get
my Rook somewhere active like to d8 D4
something then um probably it's all all
good right but here I've just made it
yeah
I have to play Rook page and okay well
not just ugly but he just starts pushing
his a pawn and I lose
oh that's pretty ugly because my king is
not just trapped momentarily but it's
trapped forever yeah so Rook D4 was
important and after that I I didn't feel
in huge danger but
yeah it wasn't super fun but uh I never
saw a moment when I was like
in real Danger
it seems that you kept the draw always
well in hand uh tell us a little bit
about what you did and then in your free
day that's a good question
um besides some tennis which
people know
know about already because
it was posted a photo was posted on
Twitter and it got like
um a million yeah I'm still getting
getting commentary on that one picture
yeah
sorry I couldn't oh he said that he's
still getting commentary on that picture
oh yeah yeah I'm I mean I'm sure all the
all the likes were because I was in it
I mean I'm not gonna lie the top two
comments on Reddit of that picture are
thank you for bringing svedler I'm gonna
avoid her using one word that was out of
there and Fabi is a cutie so I think I
think the conversation is about you too
that's very flattering um yeah and thank
you for bringing Fiddler it's basically
like it take your grandma to work day
kind of
I mean Reddit is is the the place to um
to read up on chess news isn't
absolutely oh but yeah that was one
thing and then
um I have to I have to say that I didn't
really think I couldn't think about
Chess yesterday at all
um and today I also couldn't think about
Chess whatsoever and I more or less
didn't prepare
um because my mind was elsewhere uh
uh without like going into details but
it wasn't so easy to to focus on chess
all right do you want to leave it there
yeah okay sounds good well Fabi a solid
draw here against netball you must be
satisfied considering that apparently
you can't think about Chess uh yeah no
the result is good
um other results were not so good for me
but my result was okay I guess Wesley
will also win uh we think that this
seems like it yeah well we got to this
position give us your opinion on it
doesn't look great I mean
what does what I do here because like
Knight C2 or or there is D5 like d526
you'll start shedding materials yeah
that's that's a square right and then
because let's just point to the audience
that if you play here on E5 I think you
have an ig4 yeah it's still not very
nice but yeah it's a better version of
five yeah but it's pointless because D5
King D6 just wins that pawn right well
not G2 still exists but it starts
looking very very but after King E5 this
is just terrible yeah this Knight is
completely dominated
yes okay this should be lost so I guess
Knight C2 and of King D5 King E3 and he
holds it together and he has my before
check and black can play A5 here
completely paralyzing white oh this just
looks like a zoo yeah I don't know if
there's B4 but uh you also are not
forced to play King D5 if you can maybe
play some kind of a waiting move perhaps
like a six or five might be decent here
and five can can white take the
opportunity to play F3
Maybe
sorry and now King D5 King E3 I'll take
one of three Knight before
uh King King G6 you might see two I like
I'm oh you're trying to survive this I'm
not happy but I'm just trying to hold on
like this can you yeah okay I missed I
missed that you can go back yeah yeah
there's still the H Pawn like they
should be six king of three yeah maybe
this is actually still winning for black
here yeah it probably is because King G3
Bishop six white is again dominated it
definitely doesn't seem like a great
chances here yeah yeah this is probably
probably resigns at this point I don't
like I don't even see a move there so I
don't know Knight C2 yeah F5
um D5 check by the way play
yeah Wesley is
uh is really at home in these types of
uh technicals can he play Knight G4 F5
Knight F6 like I just out of pure
desperation
can you find my D7 and 97 and Knight of
Fate I mean Bishop D4 though no uh and
97 Bishop G7 yeah and then we've
collected stuff right I don't really
believe in my G8
yeah probably not but you know like
Bishop Bishop D4 and Knight G8 oh okay
Bishop G7 I mean I I guess that and
something King E3 I I don't know it's
it's actually designed it's still a game
yeah
I think you are resigning though King
takes D5
King E6
check okay H5
ah sorry yeah there is yeah we have H5
so I actually gained weight 10 years yes
here King D4 it's not also King D4 king
of 695 is escaping oh yeah so 75.
yeah I mean this this looks close
starting to get closer too he's already
played 92 so we are
he played my G2 yeah 94 against Bishop
D4 simply we don't even play a five you
know Bishop D4 Knight F4 now no there I
played Knight G4 no he played on G2 oh
okay sorry I'm again yeah and here we go
King E5 I guess right and uh okay so D6
must be his idea right but unfortunately
even if you break up those I I have G5
there and H5 is not a queen yeah yeah
but but this is not clear clear cut
anymore no take take I mean the pawns
are getting less Knight H3 yeah G4
knight uh
but I think B3 is just falling like I go
King E5 King D4 King C3 I'm just gonna
abandon everything on the other side
yeah King E5 on the board by the way
yeah this looks pretty bad uh allowing
D6 for what it's worth okay so let's try
f 3 if we can
not D6 Fabi F3 I think we probably like
Bishop B8 probably just kind of ends the
game right Bishop B8 I was thinking
Bishop C5 actually
my point is I want to give I want to
take away neither four altogether and
then like took SpongeBob but Bishop B8
Knight E3 doesn't it seem like the end
of the world no why
oh okay but like you have no moves
King G4 next like I will just continue
denying you moves and eventually I think
this will have to collapse now
especially with the power on H4 right
yeah I think I think this has to be lost
yeah this looks terrible yeah
that might be a big victory for Wesley
it's currently on plus one and he's
taking down one of the other players
with plus one yeah for him this is huge
because he's also
in the running in the grand trust tour
right right uh if he does well if he
wins the tournament he probably clinches
clinch is the first place in the
franchise tour and uh and now he's going
to be in the clear lead
um I guess okay also alireza had a very
big day because he's
also doing well yes and uh and yet for
that that makes him lost
yeah uh yeah Maxine losing and going on
my S2 is is a big blow for him
all right well we'll let you go Favi
enjoy uh the rest of your day and we'll
see what you have tomorrow thank you
sorry sorry Fabby inquiring minds want
to know uh now that you played tennis on
the rest day uh who did you beat who did
you lose to
okay so I I played Peter first and I
lost
commentators do it again that I played
Maxim and I won
did I beat you Alejandro yes
[Laughter]
and I lost two
um a player I hadn't met before uziah
Josiah I'm telling you that you will
never see this person again you will not
allowed in the tennis court it's not
allowed any anywhere near you
it was way too good all of us no he he
was by far though yeah he was a bit
strongest tennis player Among Us yeah
all right papi thank you so much for
joining us and sharing your thoughts uh
and uh wow it was uh it was a nice
interview it was very very very very
nice peter we are having one of the most
decisive games of the sync